nous sommes en train de vivre l'une des
plus grandes révolutions que l'europe
ait jamais connu c'est une simple vérité
on a tous une peur bleue de rouge
tavannes toning bientôt avec les nazis
ça va être à nous de payer pour être
occupés pardon monsieur canal vous ne
pensez pas que la venue défendre
une pas encore destine j'ai à perdre la
raison
on n'est pas des résistants oui on est
des banquiers c'est tout je n'ai pas
envie de mettre en danger et mis les
enfants
moi aussi j'ai une famille toi aussi tu
es dans le coup je vois pas de quoi tu
parles
c'est la nouvelle mode
va quand même pas cambriolé la banque du
pays bas on n'a pas d'autre choix
vous n'avez pas la moindre idée de ce
qu'on a vécu nous avons payé pour tous
la résistance des groupes armés les
unités l'espionnage les unités de
sabotage absolument tout
[Musique]
quoi tu veux qu'on arrête pas question
j'ai pas envie qui t'arrive quelque
chose